j'ai pas envie qu'elle soit donc si vous
permettez je vais bien pas tout est une
question je vous parlais du match un
petit peu il n'y a pas grand chose à
dire oui c'est effectivement ou de
soulagement c'est c'est l'objectif qu'on
s'était fixé ce club en ligue 1 une
cinquième année
on savait depuis quand même temps déjà 4
ans apprend comment parler de 25 ans que
c'était pas rêver donc le faire une
cinquième année c'est un casting pour le
club sur le match je trouve que c'est
pas plus important le contenu du match
ce qu'on fait habituellement
ce que je voudrais surtout vous dire
c'est que j'ai évidemment une pensée ce
soir pour un homme que j'aime que
j'apprécie et mon président jean même
s'il n'est plus depuis jeudi soir et que
je lui avais promis que je ne serai pas
l'entraîneur qui ne serai pas le
président qui ferait descendre le club
med 2 donc je sais que ce soir il est
très heureux
le stade malherbe même s'il est en
souffrance il entre par les événements
que vous connaissez je vais pas les
commenter parce que j'ai pas c'est pas
mon rôle mais en tout cas ce que je peux
dire c'est que
pour ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est
qu'un homme comme lui qui a oeuvré qui a
tant donné pour le stade malherbe
je pense que l'on aurait mérité une
autre sortie que celle qu'il a vécue
donc je suis aussi heureux de l'hommage
que lui a rendu les supporters tous les
gens qui les témoins de ça mais
franchement je pense vraiment que ça
méritait mieux que ça beaucoup beaucoup
mieux concède que la ch'ti donc il a
arrêté la victime pour venir alors ça
c'est sur un plan un peu plus générale
après j'ai une histoire avec cet homme
moi qui ai assez importante monde le
sait j'ai une réelle amitié et dans la
vie on a toujours une des rencontres des
croyants lacunes dans la ville des poids
y en a plusieurs mais quand on fait un
métier comme le bien et il faut toujours
qu'à un moment et un homme qui vous
tendent la main qui croient en vous et
moi cet homme ça a été gens consentants
d'une part elle a fait ça
hélas toujours aussi soutenu les moments
difficiles et dans d'autres mamans aussi
important de mobiliser est un homme qui
m'a appris qui m'a montré surtout la
loyauté je parlais de rentrer dans les
détails de toute cette histoire là mais
si je vous raconte ça c'est pour vous
dire à quel point moi j'ai souffert de
j'ai mal vécu plutôt de sa souffrance sa
sortie et la fin de son histoire le plus
stable
alors si je vous raconte ça c'est parce
que hier j'ai rencontré le nouveau
président j'ai le sergent je sais bien
moment-là souhaité nos preuves et il
était question dans cet entretien de
deux choses une première c'est de parler
du match qu'ils avaient
le samedi c'est bien normal de la part
d'un président est une deuxième c'était
se fixe un rendez vous dimanche en cas
de maintien comme cette passoire pour
évoquer une future collaboration et donc
à travers les mots ont été employés
j'ai compris qu'il y avait aussi une
volonté de continuer avec moi je suis
pas trompé ou réponse à la question en
tout cas c'est comme ça je pense donc je
lui dire que contenu du tout ce que je
viens de vous dire j'ai des relations
avec jean françois fortin
je ne pouvais pas être l'entraîneur du
stade
je le remercie la retenue parole parce
que je lui avais dit que ça des restes
entre lui et moi il a tenu parole
alors je sais bien dans tous les
journaux se démarquer partout j'ai été
dégagée mais les m'assurer que ce n'est
pas vrai j'ai contacté par l'entraîneur
mais bon je vous ai aussi dit pour les
locaux souvent quand on les lit on a son
destin entre ses mains et que j'ai
toujours une veste entre eux cette
saison sans que j'étais libre en fin de
saison mais que
un moment dans la vie il faut savoir
avant elle reconnaissant du monde je ne
peux pas entraîner le stade malherbe
compte tenu des choses de la façon dont
les choses se sont passées si
jean-françois était sorti d'une autre
façon qu'ils avaient une certaine
continuité
après une discussion avec lui c'est
quelque chose évidemment j'aurais pu
envisager parce que j'aurais jamais
imaginé rester longtemps cela aussi
longtemps
j'ai appris à aimer cette région a aimé
cette ville je me suis fait des amis des
vrais et j'aime ce club c'est aussi
après lé secret
donc c'est un moment compliqué pour moi
d'à côté mais voilà j'ai envie de rester
fidèle à ce que je suis à mes valeurs
donc voilà donc le président au sel pour
que sont pâles en ce moment parce que je
l'avais dit cela ne serait comme ça
maintenant je voudrais pas quitter cette
salle sans remercier tous les joueurs
j'ai eu sous ma responsabilité pendant
que j'ai entraînés
cette équipe même ceux qui n'ont pas
joué même sur laquelle les problèmes
tous m'ont apporté quelque chose et tous
ont une part de réussite dans ce qu'on a
fait parce que je vais le redire quand
même mais c'est une totale réussite
monté en deux ans est restée 58 en ligue
1 c'est un exploit
les jeux le maintien tenu du budget du
club et des effectifs qu'on avait chaque
année je voudrais aussi avoir une pensée
beaucoup de remercier mon staff
jean marie duriez et jean mach projets
qui ont été des gens au delà de leurs
compétences qu'on était des gens fidèles
loyaux tout temps et de celle ci la
matière dans les moments qu'on a vécus
les rues matière anne valette mais ils
ont toujours été là du pire
voilà je peux pas toutes les citer mais
tous les gens qui ont travaillé avec qui
j'ai travaillé qui ont collaboré à cette
réussite les remercie
ils font du coeur et ses jeux les
associés évidemment grandement
moi je considère comme une réussite et
j'espère qu'à 36 direct
[Musique]
donc voilà ça s'arrête satar est
aujourd'hui et
mais c'est la ville c'était partie de la
vie d'un trader
[Musique]
puis je vais aussi finir par vous parce
que vous faites partie intégrante de mon
métier j'ai toujours essayé dans mes
relations avec vous d'être honnête je
pense que si je le suis mais d'être
sincère de pavant langue de bois
d'expliquer ce que je faisais de
pourquoi je l'objet voilà et j'ai aimé
ces échanges j'ai toujours essayé de
mettre en place une relation gagnant
gagnant je sais vous ai besoin
d'informations c'est qu'on peut pas tout
donné mais essayez quand même donné des
choses vous et de la matière quelques
fois sans rien vous donner vous n'en
avez trouvé matière ça ça fait partie du
métier
mais en tout cas voilà ça y est j'ai
apprécié sur tous ces moments là et que
aujourd'hui ça s'arrête au stade un
habitant de camp peut-être qu'un jour
dans l'occasion de se croiser j'espère
je voulais vous remercier pour ça et
puis
oui j'oublié juste une petite chose
quand même qui me tenait à coeur parce
que je
alémanique les manifestations qui
avaient eu ce soir je me suis représenté
devant la porte et tout ça n'est pas
parce que jean françois yen allait venir
pour souhaiter mieux que ce soit lui qui
prennent de cette rivière là et puis
malgré tout ce qui est arrivé pour dire
pour leur dire que j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour eux je les aime aussi je
les ai toujours défendu nos relations
soient un petit peu pas trop bien passé
les sept dernières saisons mais comme
quand on aime des genres je dis jamais
ce club je leur souhaite le meilleur
je leur souhaite surtout donc le
meilleur c'est faire au moins aussi bien
puisqu'on a fait
je souhaite que la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante que nous valons traders face
d'eux des supporter en ligue 1 pendant
les cinq prochains c'est tout bonnement
la décision je suis à s'expliquer alors
que jamais
[Musique]